[Musik]
manchmal wünschte du wärst echt und
dabei ist heute die war auch toll gute
Nacht Barbie
[Musik]
happy Harmonie
bleibt für sie sind
[Musik]
ellas Wunsch in Erfüllung und unsere
zauberhafte Torten barbie ist aus der
Barbie Welt in die echte Welt gefallen
hey Baby hey bar
bie hey Barbie
ich liebe euch
[Musik]
na dann back ich doch jetzt mal eine
Barbie Torte
ich habe ich eine Ganache die zubereitet
wurde aus Himbeerpüree mit Sahne
aufgegossen und dann kommt da weiße
Schokolade rein mit etwas
Lebensmittelfarbe und voila ist hier
eine himbeerweise Schokoladen Ganache
und hier hat die liebes Sally auch schon
Böden vorgebacken und zwar aus dem
Mantel Rührteigboden vier Böden
vorgebacken zweimal im 16er Ring zweimal
im 14er Ring am besten bereitet ihr
sowas sogar einen Tag vorher zu ich muss
jetzt nicht zubereiten denn es ist schon
vorgebacken
werden die Böden hier einmal
zugeschnitten damit Sie gleich gefüllt
werden können
dann nehme ich jetzt hier ein cakeboard
setzt es hier auf meinen Drehteller da
kommt jetzt bisschen Ganache drauf zum
festkleben dann könnt ihr den ersten
großen Boden aufsetzen und jetzt immer
wieder mit der Ganache bestreichen und
den nächsten Boden drüber setzen
[Musik]
der Tortenboden
perfekt ich halte mal kurz mein minimi
nebendran wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt
da ist die Taille unten das Kleid passt
schon die übrigen Böden brauche ich
jetzt nicht es kommt jetzt erstmal ein
Kühlschrank damit es schön fest wird zum
Zuschneiden so schnell geht das hier
jetzt ist der Kuchen gut gekühlt ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach nur einen
Strohhalm also den Trinkhalm damit ich
einfach bisschen Stabilität habe und
schneide jetzt hier eine kleidform so
das heißt mit dem Messer von oben nach
unten
und die Reste einfach aufbewahren
kleinen Boden brauch ich da oben noch
und dann kommt jetzt hier einfach
nochmal Ganache drumherum und die muss
gar nichts zur glatt sein denn da kommt
ja gleich ein schönes Kleidchen drüber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
perfekt
das ist meine Tortenplatte hier kommt
die Torte gleich drauf und damit sie
nicht verrutscht hier ein bisschen
Ganache
und dann kann ich es hier draufsetzen
jetzt kann ich das Stäbchen rausnehmen
denn ich muss jetzt Platz machen für die
Barbie ich habe jetzt hier einfach die
Beine in Frischhaltefolie gewickelt denn
die wird ja da reingesteckt das wird
eine Barbie doch okay
das Oberteil mache ich gleich aus
Fondant und von der Höhe her passt das
heißt hier in der Mitte einfach mal was
ausstechen was ungefähr die Größe hat
oben nehme ich bisschen mehr raus
und weiter unten etwas weniger
bisschen was ausstopfen damit sie stabil
steht
und dann kommt einfach nur noch etwas
Geller Strom herum
so einfach geht's und dann könnt ihr ihn
dazwischen Zeit schon mal Fondant kneten
in eurer Wunschfarbe ich nehme jetzt
etwas pink und rosa und wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr etwas Cellulose Pulver
einkneten also CMC damit das Kleid auch
fest wird und gut aushärten kann
[Musik]
man so ein bisschen besser damit
modellieren also diese Barbie bekommt
zwei jetzt ein schönes Kleid aber ihr
wisst eine Barbie kann genauso wie eine
Frau alles sein sie kann Polizistin sein
sie kann Ingenieurin sein sie kann
Astronaut werden sie kann am
obergerichtshof Arbeiten eine Frau kann
alles sein
aber meine Barbie bekommt dazu Kleid
besser essen kann
fahre immer so Streifen dünn ausrollen
denn dann spart man sich auch so dieses
einmal im gesamten drumrum legen
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann diesen Stoff habt könnt
ihr ihn gerne auch etwas dünner
gestalten könnt hier ein boltool nehmen
und einfach den Rand das Fondant so ein
bisschen ausdünnen weil wenn es dann
fällt sieht nicht aus wie von dann
sondern wirklich wie so ein Stück Stoff
und dann könnt ihr das ganze jetzt hier
in Falten
legen und dann als Kleid anlegen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das Kleid fertig
geschneidert an der Taille bekommt
Barbie jetzt noch einen Saum denk ich
einfach so ein bisschen Fondant
drumherum und fürs Oberteil Rolle ich
jetzt noch mal etwas von dann aus
stechen Herz aus und das wird dann schon
so ein bisschen strukturiert
die bekommt hinten jetzt einfach nur
noch so ein Streifen drüber
tragen das ist die bauchfrei Barbie
schön also theoretisches Barbie jetzt
fertig aber ihr könnt sie gerne noch aus
dekorieren ich finde ja es fehlt noch
ein bisschen Glitzer und ein bisschen
Glanz ich nehme jetzt etwas
backtrennspray ihr könnt auch ein
Kokosöl nehmen und einfach mit dem
Pinsel hier so ein bisschen auf dem
Kleid verteilen dann nimmt man auch so
ein bisschen die bäckerstärke weg mit
der man den Fondant ausgerollt hat und
der erste Glanz hier der verschwindet
dann auch wieder also keine Sorge es
glänzt dann nicht so sehr jetzt wird
natürlich noch ein bisschen glitzern ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach so ein Glitzer
Pulver in Silber ihr könnt ein Pinsel
nehmen oder einfach drauf sprühen und
ich mache das jetzt aber nur hier unten
und lass es nach oben hin so ein
bisschen auslaufen
[Musik]
oh nein
es glänzt es ist pink ich liebe es wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr noch fürs Kleid
ein paar Details machen und zwar hier
aus dem Fondant der mit cmc-pulver
verknetet ist den ganz dünn ausrollen
dann Herzchen ausstechen mit dem
balltool ausdünnen und dann in so eine
Eierschale geben zum Trocknen und hier
klebe ich jetzt mit etwas Isomalt das
ist so ein Zuckerersatz diese
Blüten einfach an das ist praktisch wie
so ein Heißkleber ihr könnt natürlich
auch Zucker schmelzen aber Zucker hat so
den geringeren Rauchpunkt das heißt
Zucker karamellisiert einfach früher
wird schneller braun ist normal
karamellisiert einfach ein bisschen
später und so kann ich es einfach ganz
schnell ankleben was sie auch nehmen
könnt ist ähm zuckerkleber oder einfach
etwas Wasser aber mit dem Hells halt
wirklich sofort und wenn die Blüten
hinten noch nicht ganz fest sind könnt
ihr sie mit etwas Zewa was ihr vorher
zusammen knallt einfach befestigen und
den Form bringen und dann hätten sie so
gut aus
und sobald die Blüten ausgehärtet sind
könnt ihr dann das Papier entfernen dann
sieht man schon ganz gut jetzt hat die
schöne Form und jetzt einfach nur noch
fertig stellen denn ich würde sagen da
kommt jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
Glitzer drauf
[Musik]
ich habe eine Torte für dich gebacken
danke
dir ja ja
[Musik]
danke dass du mich ins echte Leben
geholt hast okay ich gehe wieder zurück
ins Babyland
[Musik]
mal schauen was sie mir als nächstes
Wünsche
[Musik]